we're in our quest to give ourselves a
little bit of a mathematical
underpinning of definite integrals of
various combinations of trig functions
so it'll be hopefully straightforward
for us to actually find the coefficients
our Fourier coefficients which we're
going to do a few videos from now and
we've already started going down this
path we've established that the definite
integral from 0 to 2pi of sine of M T DT
is equal to 0 that the cosine the
definite integral of cosine M T DT is
equal to 0 for any nonzero integer M
actually we can generalize that a little
bit for sine of M T it could be for any
M actually and I if you don't believe me
I encourage you
let me write this for any for any
integer M this top integral is going to
be 0 and this second integral for any
four nonzero non zero integer integer M
and you can see if you had zero in this
second case it would be cosine of 0 T so
this would just evaluate to 1 so you
just be integrating the value 1 from 0
to 2pi and so that's going to have a non
zero value so with those two out of the
way let's let's go a little bit deeper
get a little bit more foundations so I'm
now I now want to establish that the
definite integral from 0 to 2pi of sine
of M T times cosine of of cosine of n at
T and T DT that this equals 0 for any
any integers integers m and n and they
could even be the same M they don't have
to necessarily be different but they
could be different how do we do this
well let's just rewrite let's just
rewrite this part right over here
leveraging some trig identities and if
it's completely unfamiliar to you I
encourage you to review your trig
identities on Khan Academy so this is
the same thing as a definite integral
from 0 to 2pi this sine of M T times
cosine NT we can rewrite it at using the
product to sum formulas so that is let
me use
different color here so this thing right
over here that I've underlined in
magenta I'm squaring off in magenta that
can be re-written as 1/2 times sine of M
plus n T sine of M plus n T plus sine
sine of M minus n M minus n t and then
let me just close that with a DT DT now
if we were to just rewrite this using
some of our integral properties we could
rewrite it as so this part over here we
could and let's assume we distribute the
1/2 so we're going to distribute the 1/2
and use some of our integral properties
and so what are we going to get so this
part roughly right over here we could
rewrite as 1/2 times the definite
integral from 0 to 2 pi of sine of M
plus n T DT and then this part once you
distribute the 1/2 and you use some
integration properties this could be
plus 1/2 times the definite integral
from 0 to 2pi of sine of M minus n m- n
T DT now what are each of these things
going to be equal to well isn't this
right over here isn't that just some
integer if I have to take the sum of two
arbitrary integers that's going to be
some integer so that's going to be some
integer and this 2 is going to be some
integer right over here
and we've already established that the
definite integral of sine of some
integer times T DT is 0 so by this first
thing that we already showed this is
going to be equal to 0 and that's going
to be equal to 0 doesn't matter that
you're multiplying by 1/2 1/2 times 0 0
1/2 times 0 is 0
this whole thing is going to evaluate to
0 so there you go we've
Reuven that as well